hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry and I'm
Aaron welcome two reasons to see when we
give you reasons to see and not to see
Spring Breakers
so let's hang out for college girls who
land in jail after robbing a restaurant
to fund their spring break vacation find
themselves bailed out by a drug and arms
dealer who wants them to do some dirty
work for him reason to see number one
James Franco yeah this guy embodied
alien that's the guy's name he's like a
combination of ninja from Dion toward
hey Rock queasy jibs like a bad
interpretation of Scarface like come up
with by like a kid that's wearing a Yolo
snapback you know what's weird is that
you could feel that's probably is
history like he is the epitome of the
most horrible like sludge at the bottom
of American culture yeah cliche as it
sounds like James Franco is this guy
like he's so good at playing this
whacked-out character it's a and I
imagine for him it's a fun character to
play yeah it's weird cuz you just feel
like you're just spying on this guy's
existence yeah and I sort of fun but
also very unsettling manner you get he's
fun to watch really the same time you
don't want to be this guy's friend you
know I kind of imagine like he has done
what he does in this movie before just
you know maybe with one girl this year
he hit he hit the [ __ ] jackpot yeah
reason to see number two Selena Gomez
she was one of the biggest surprises to
me and yeah like she's very believable
it's kind of interesting because she's
not in it as much as you think she'd be
in it
want to give anything away but you know
she is like a very important character
to all the messages of this movies
really trying to get across and she does
a great job in the role very emotional a
lot more depth than her performances on
Wizards of Waverly Place and so kudos
easily an A+ you're very hot I like you
if you ever want to have sex she let me
feel like she's 15 don't care she looks
like she's 15 I know her actual age and
that's what matters I was really
actually very pleasantly surprised by
Selena Gomez because just like somebody
who's only known for dating Justin
Bieber and starring on Disney Channel
show I don't imagine to act like a human
being she is if nothing else she is our
audience in search nobody yeah none of
the other girls nor James Franco really
do we get to kind of emotionally connect
with and see yeah yeah I can see how
this is fun I can see how this is like
new and exciting just sort of marveling
at this Bacchanalia going up but then
when it gets scary yeah I want to leave
like she see she's really the most light
any viable heir apparent she's the three
she out of all the girls she's the most
three-dimensional one for the air yeah
our most obvious hero yeah one she's the
one who would behave probably the way
closest to the way most of us would
because I mean this this movie has a lot
of over-the-top sort of surreal fantasy
to it and she is the one who grounds it
reason is seen number three the
directing / editing so it's out there
this was for all three of us are we
popped our Harmony Korine cherry with
this movie hella yes yes the first
Korean experiences our first Karenin and
it's I'm glad that we were able to do
this together we were we were honestly
if you hate this film or love it I don't
really see walking out of this movie
going hits whatever cuz they do the
Harmony Korine really knew what kind of
movie he wanted to make he must have
accomplished exactly what he wanted to
do and then it's however you take that
thing yeah like the person I went like I
sort of loved the movie and the person I
went with hated the movie and everything
they were saying of why they hated it I
was like but don't you get the point of
that that's why I love it
and because there's so much to explore
in this movie that's what I love about
it's really open to interpretation even
though it doesn't seem like it would be
based off the trailer but you know it's
like it's trashy it's violent it'll
there's a lot of sexuality a lot of pot
a lot of cocaine yeah it's just it's
weird because it's a party movie yet it
feels surprisingly dangerous at the same
time with the Stars behind it and with
James Franco looking the way he does a
lot of people might mistake this for
being a comedy yeah it's really not
though yeah it's sort of like it's crazy
the whole thing moves like a montage
it's a black hole comedy the best way
I've found to describe this movie is
it's kind of like it's like a sensory
head trip through the thumping neon lit
tanning oils clad you know a teenage
wasteland of the American Dream my
favorite thing about it was especially
with the directing and the editing with
it working together so well was that it
felt a lot like a dream it was just such
a hypnotic experience and a lot of the
themes of this movie is you know
escaping from reality chasing that next
high you know looking for some type of
party dream and you really get that
there Selena Gomez in this film and it's
cool to see a movie that really captures
that emotion just to the direction and
editing of this film it has the style
world it'll jump around it'll show you
something from a few minutes away and
then come back to a previous event and
then loop the dialogue but that's it
just like it feels like a dream where
everything's a little bit scattered yeah
yeah you know when you look back on the
dream you're able to put the pieces to
say it feels like a dream I say it feels
like a trip it feels like you were yeah
I was like you're listening because I
mean there are really two girls in this
whole crew that are the absolute worst
it feels like you are intimately
experiencing the inside of the worst of
these girls heads and those yes exactly
it's it's weird I wouldn't call it like
a documentary but it's like a
documentary of a weird trip because you
kind of feel like as an audience member
it says feel like this is Spring Break
you know if you if you really break it
down it's because the movie starts off
feeling like just a big ass party film
you know there's a lot of tits and
drinking and stuff and then
of course there's dark elements the
spring-break to that we start to feel
when you're loading your body with all
that [ __ ] there's like that music video
gloss that MTV thing and it's like it's
it's almost like eating too much cotton
candy like the way they capture these
events it's like after a while it's like
there's so much sexuality that's not
sexy anymore this sort of portrait of
this weird fucked-up youth subculture
yeah but it's it it's conflicting
because it's like he's reveling in it
and accosting it at the same time yeah
well I think in order to get the point
across you have this you have to like
see what is really yeah what is
appreciated about it but then that's the
thing is you start to go and deeper and
deeper into the world and it's like and
maybe this is such an empty world after
all
yeah you know because you have to see
why these characters will are kind of
wanting to do it what I really look at
the way the film is edited there are two
ways to look at it either this is so
trying to promote the subjective
experience of this of these girls trips
and like what of this just vacuous
madness or harmony cruise just really
[ __ ] up and ten things happen in the
movie and to pad it out to 90 minutes it
needs to stab those 10 things happen
four times I just wanted to shoot a
bunch of naked girls and I love how
we're talking about it because like
Aaron clearly has you know different
opinions than I do and you know Jerry
houses things to say as well but and
that's why I love it is because it's
open to interpretation because it's hard
to say who's right or wrong it's like it
just depends on what you take from this
type of movie man reason to see number
four the music dude dubstep is my life
I got my dark tanning oil
lay out by the pool you know it's like
that Spring Break youth cultures all
people who want to live in a music video
it almost seems like and so this music
this movie takes on a lot of those
elements and it has the music to go
along with it rested there is a good
point where the music doesn't stop stop
being bubblegummy for a moment where
they really try and punch just the it
becomes discordant and it becomes a
glean it becomes waiting and it does it
at the right time that's why I love
about the music is a lot of the songs I
don't know if there's any original music
in it so there might be some original
music but most of it are songs that are
been selected for this movie and each
song choice seemed to match the scenes
of depending on the mood they were going
for if they want to do a party or go
dark like the song choices just really
help amplify the scene even more reason
to see number 5
cinematography well it looks great split
decision number one the girls you know
I'm kind of back and forth when it comes
to the girls in this because Selena
Gomez is the only 3-dimensional girl out
of the four yeah because the other ones
are two-dimensional now I can actually
see what the point of that is depending
on you know how you take this movie I
can sort of get it but I felt like I
want to watch the more interesting film
if you are able to discern the three of
them other than enough knowing their
celebrity name I think all three of the
girls were great for what they had to do
but I think Vanessa Hudgens didn't have
much to work with in the script and her
One Direction was oh your forms are just
talk like a porn star whereas she had a
counterpart that was just as you know
[ __ ] up in her actions was her
accomplice Ashley Benson yeah Ashley
Benson and Ashley Benson felt more a
little more dimensional a little more
fleshed out with the way she was
portrayed yeah great actor can bring
depth to a performance even if the
script is not talking about their
backstory yeah what they're thinking or
feeling unless they're Vanessa Hudgens
so I I could actually see what you're
talking about you know I wasn't as
bothered by Vanessa Hudgens just because
I was like super bothered yeah I just
took it as there's supposed to be
they're both supposed to be
two-dimensional but I will say I'm
reflecting on it I think Ashley Benson
does bring more depth than Vanessa
Hudgens since they're pretty much
playing the same character yeah they are
they are two sides of the same there are
two heads to the same really [ __ ] up
two-headed snake I get why you have four
girls and they all sort of go on a
stepping ladder of statuses yeah so I
get why you know the Vanessa Hudgens
character is sort of the most be
one-dimensional because I feel like it
sort of completes that gradient where
it's just like you have the most human
the one who's kind of floating around in
purgatory and then the one who's pretty
bad and then the one who's just like the
complete tit yeah yeah it makes sense to
have two dimensional characters because
it kind of goes along with a message
that I think there's a message in the
song of like how this lifestyle can lead
to a lot of emptiness and these girls
clearly have very empty lives decision
number two the nudity
who doesn't like a movie with four main
characters who are just in bikinis the
whole time and a movie filled with a lot
of tips and a naked James Franco almost
yeah what are you doing I was pointing
at you because you're the guy you don't
get to say that you're like you know
this like you know checking your your
male privilege and you're being this
champion of empowered women but still
staring at their ass you don't get the
[ __ ] but do that to be fair this movie
stairs that everyone's everything
because everyone is half naked all the
time
no because it's like there's a point
like say the the bit in the strip club
there's like eight just oh yeah that
closed on on some like big jiggly ass
titties and just like no you you go
there's a scene in act 1 to where
there's they're playing in the hall and
there's just like shots of their legs up
and they're zooming in on Selena Gomez's
crotch yeah yeah yeah
that was a she even gets like this weird
like creepy camera days late on her too
this has it to be their world it didn't
bother ya it bothered me because just
like you it feels like you don't get to
rub
well in the exploitation like the
exploitative and exploit like you don't
get to revel in that ugly seedy
exploitation of these like of these
girls and of these people's sexuality
while saying oh yeah this is pretty bad
it felt like you don't get to have it
both ways you don't get to say oh this
hyper sexualization is bad and it's
destructive and it's you know it's at
its core morally vacuous and dude
titties you don't get to say those two
statements at the same time like that's
[ __ ] teleologically [ __ ] say I
feel like you it's like he wanted to you
wanted you to feel alert and then feel
part of the party but then also feel the
darkness of the party and then I feel
like he wanted you to feel like you're
sort of in those characters she's like
Selena Gomez is the first one to sort of
like because she's like in love with all
of it because this is like a spiritual
thing to her and then it's like oh this
is such a sick thing to be a part of I
don't want to be a part of it anymore
and I think you wanted you to feel that
way
see I can I can get on board with both
of the things you guys are saying cuz
I'm still sort of thinking about this
aspect of the movie and I again I kind
of took it as one of those things where
it's like no no no but look at it
there's so much of it and look at how it
key this is when it's all up in your
face that's sort of what I took out a
lot of this movie experience was sort of
like are you sure you want to live that
hip-hop lifestyle that's thrust upon us
by popular culture like are you sure you
want to be a gangster cuz look at what
happens and yeah but I left going I
don't want to do any of this [ __ ] some
kids in one world be crazy some kids
want to be a doctor
I just wanted to be bad so all this
stuff being said then what's everybody
give it what's the consensus here
Ryan's consensus I would have to say
there are a lot of reasons to watch
spring breakers there are a lot of
reasons to watch spring breakers it's a
film full of debauchery with some weird
messages and it feels like a hypnotic
dream and you're either gonna hate it or
love it
or be like Aaron and be okay bears
consensus
there are some niche weird postmodern
reasons to see spring breakers there's
some it's weird postmodern reasons to
see spring breakers at the end of the
day and trying to sort of summarize this
more or less what's supposed to be an
art movie into something grander or
something more you know cohesive it kind
of fell apart in my hands it's like I
mean and the weird thing is I had fun
Sherri's consensus Spring Breakers as
the reason movies are made spring
breakers as the recent movies are made
what I do like so much about the overall
experience is that it seems like
everyone's got a different opinion and
we've talked for like an hour about it
and there's clearly still more to talk
about
yeah and this is what I love about
movies in general is when this thing
happens you know it's like we've
reviewed a lot of movies but like this
is a lot of stuff going on and I like
that sort of stuff alright guys thanks
for checking out our video please go
ahead and comment below by telling us
your reasons to see or not to see spring
breakers and if you want to check out my
straight to-the-point review of spring
breakers if you want to know what the
difference is just through the title
it's straight to the point
Spring Breakers click on the link right
here and if you want to see more reasons
to see episodes click on the link right
here last but not least if you want to
get updated every time a new review is
out click on Aaron like him
click Aaron come on go ahead touch him
it's ok no it's not
touching I'm going to touch it I want
people to touch me I don't like being
touched she's just lately and giggly
when I touch it oh you all probably
don't use the mouse pad in the air oh
just touch your computer screen yeah but
but when you're done please do click the
subscribe button otherwise you know it's
like touching unless you have a
touchscreen it won't work
yeah you know unless you have a Windows
surface cool subscribe
you